có thể nhìn cạnh những tưu trần trong những cái đồng trí được quan truyền.
Nếu trong các cái quy định của đàn, trong lợi trọng giữ thiệu nhìn sự tham gia bộ trí chỉ
mà lý thử hóa mối vốn, các đồng trí đặc biệt quan tâm tên 5 đêm cậm.
Nhất là một tâm dình chỉ là cú gàn có khả năng,
đứng được tự trụ của đất nước.
Tài là con năng lực với đạo, chỉ huy, khuy mô cú gàn.
Cú bàn là có, quy tính chính chỉ liêm chính, mối biểu tợ, để mọi người nói theo không tập.
Tự là có khả năng chỉ thay nghị quyết thình, kép quả thành quả có thể nó đếm được.
Nó là có đủ sự bàn, cảm thấy tinh thần và tẻ chất,
để chức được áp lực, cường độ là người trong những kỳ tìm mối vốn, có thể là những nghiệp kỳ tìm theo.